hi guys dr. Berg here in this video
we're going to talk about an amazing
mineral a trace mineral called zinc it's
actually a cofactor for over a hundred
enzymes seems that these enzymes these
magical proteins required trace minerals
to actually be activated somehow need
manganese some need magnesium 70 calcium
but a lot of them need zinc so let's
just talk about the different functions
zinc is involved in an enzyme that helps
you control your pH of the blood of the
stomach and of the urine so if you have
a pH problem and you can't seem to
balance it out it could be just a simple
zinc deficiency to absorb zinc you need
a real good acid stomach so those people
who take anti acids develop zinc
deficiencies so zinc aids in reducing
allergies and histamines that stuff that
causes mucus congestion in your sinuses
or your lungs
most people with allergies are zinc
deficient then we have the common cold
which most of the time it's viral in
nature so zinc will speed up the time of
recovery zinc also controls growth in
the child your hair like you can have
alopecia and it could be a zinc
deficiency or nail issues skin issues
fimA psoriasis I mean if you think about
all these different creams that people
put on the skin there's ink based zinc
also improves acne so if you're
deficient in zinc you can also be
susceptible to bacterial infections or
viral infections zinc also prevents
diarrhea so men that are getting
estrogen dominant they're getting breast
tissue they had problems with libido sex
drive they should start taking zinc in
the form of zinc that I would recommend
is called zinc or cane it seems to be
the highest quality zinc based on
absorption alright thanks for watching
hi guys hey listen I created a pretty
amazing evaluation quiz down below that
actually analyzes your symptoms to find
the cause the root cause of all of your
symptoms the most likely cause so take
the quiz now and we'll send you report